in Rainbow six siege small tactical
choices always lead to big consequences
every round is a new lesson in what you
could have done better with your
mistakes acting as a stern teacher
taking these lessons to heart and
adjusting your team's strategy
accordingly keeps each match feeling
fresh and exciting the thrill of seeing
your plan finally succeed is what makes
siege not only a compelling shooter but
one of the best examples of teamwork
tactics and crack shooting out there
despite its evolution over the past four
years Rainbow six siege has always been
a battle between attackers and defenders
over a single objective there are five
operators per team each with their own
special gadgets that can be used to slow
the attackers assaults or poke holes in
the defenders fortifications pushing the
objective and finding an opening to take
and protect it gives the attacking side
a steep rewarding climb to victory and
it's the defenders job to knock them
down and keep them from reaching that
summit siege incentivizes teamwork and
when a group of players execute a
coordinated assault it results in some
of the most exciting moments you can
experience in a first-person shooter
siege has a particularly large focus on
learning and utilizing each operators
unique gadget to assist in taking or
holding the objective the attacking
side's abilities range from breaching
reinforced walls and creating new doors
to dismantling defender gadgets and
using cameras to reveal enemy locations
choosing the right operator for yourself
and creating a good team of abilities
that work well together can make a
heavily fortified room much easier to
breach on the defending side operator
gadgets consist largely of tools that
slow the attackers pursuit or prevent it
altogether mute signal disruptors
disable the use of any electronic
gadgets within their range while a
well-placed welcome mat from frost can
trap an unsuspecting attacker serving
them up for a free kill shot the gadgets
are what makes sieges combat distinct
from other shooters and while you'll
likely get into at least one firefight
per round using your gadget effectively
to slow the enemy can be just as
rewarding as nailing that clutch
headshot and in siege the guns feel
dangerous some are even powerful enough
to destroy the environment each guns
strengths and handling feel appropriate
for its type and size this is
particularly true for marksman rifles
which are capable of dropping an enemy
in a single shot the sound each one
makes
fits the damage it deals on the other
end loud and lethal
there are multiple ways for both teams
to pressure each other and those who
aren't ready for it will be upended and
eliminated the attackers could be moving
toward the objective cautiously while
the defenders plan to rush them catch
them off-guard and force them to slip
out of there slower more comfortable
pace the regular shift between slow and
steady and heart-pounding immediacy is
exhilarating especially when just a few
seconds can change the entire momentum
of a match the slower moments require a
calm hand taking your time and waiting
for the right moment can be
nerve-wracking but patience and proper
execution with your teammates makes for
exceptionally satisfying gunplay and
teamwork as you take out your opponents
one by one and pull out a victory
learning the maps is as if not more
important than learning your characters
and you learn each one almost
unintentionally as you breach and
protect different rooms the subtlety of
sieges idiosyncrasies makes personal
progress over time feel profound knowing
that you can see the top of a staircase
from a certain window likely learned
from being shot from that same window
can give you the edge over a distracted
team sieges learning curve is not small
but it's not particularly steep either
you'll need to spend a long time
learning the particulars but it's an
outstanding journey with rewarding
moments that'll make you feel like
you're improving every match
[Music]
what I'm for remaining
over the past four years Ubisoft has
improved siege from something that had a
great base to start with into one of the
best multiplayer experiences around each
new season has brought new reasons to
keep playing without it ever feeling
stale the introduction of new operators
obviously brings new abilities to use or
contend with but it often changes how
previous operators are viewed and
approached as well of course siege has
had its fair share of missteps but the
game we have today has ironed out many
of them Ubisoft has proven itself
receptive and expeditious when it comes
to dealing with the game's issues some
operators have received buffs while
stronger highly picked operators have
seen the exact opposite it can be
frustrating when your favorite operator
gets nerfed
but a lot of these changes have made
overpowered characters fall in line
without completely diminishing the
satisfaction of playing them several
maps have also received updates from
slight changes to complete overhauls
nearly all of sieges maps are excellent
except for that damn favela and these
reworks have only improved their layouts
seeing your favorite operator lose a
specific attachment or secondary gadget
can be disheartening at first but their
removal grants new opportunities to
learn and grow as a player likewise
losing the hallways of a map you fell in
love with can hurt but it doesn't take
long to warm up to the changes some of
the reworked maps are now among sieges
best
ubisoft's constant battle with toxicity
has yielded some good results and while
it's not perfect it's become a much more
manageable issue that you no longer have
to feel trapped by Ubisoft has been
proactive in removing toxic players from
its game and introducing new tools that
improve the overall experience
for example friendly-fire reversal has
caused a significant decrease in team
killing as players are now able to
police themselves and prevent a toxic
player from causing any further damage
of course you can't have a multiplayer
game in 2020 without an in-game shop and
siege has a big one most headgear
uniforms skins and operators can be
purchased with the free in-game currency
there are also some items that require
the use of real money such as the annual
operator past and elite uniforms the
cosmetics are beautifully designed
sometimes changing the entire motif of a
specific operator however they're not
always handled in a way that feels fair
limited-time cosmetics and the recently
implemented battle passes can encourage
you to play or pay more than you
initially wanted or intended to these
micro transactions don't affect the
gameplay or your enjoyment of it as
siege is fulfilling enough on its own
but it's still an unneeded carrot on a
stick that comes off more obnoxious than
rewarding
Rainbow six siege has always been a game
about making tactical decisions and
dealing with their consequences but with
every new year of operators and changes
the options have been refined and
increased to make for firefights that
are as engaging as they are
unpredictable learning the various
operators and how to breach or protect a
room with them can be a slow crawl but
siege makes it easy to understand what
your mistakes are thanks in part to
seeing both sides of every match it
rewards patience persistence and
teamwork and over the past four years
sieges not only become hubie softs crown
jewel but also one of the best
first-person shooters ever made
[Music]
remaining
[Music]